[Music]
so the next project just to give you
guys a little rundown
as you can see i'm starting to put out
youtube specific videos so i've already
put out three videos on puzzle solving
so i'm gonna be recording i'm gonna be
trying to do a video a day
on various topics so the next one is
gonna be i'm gonna try to refute another
gambit
now i wanna i wanna know this the the
refuting gambit series that's gonna
continue
um is there something that you guys
would like to see like is there any
particular gambit or anything you would
like to know how to play against
all right n row no plus seven so this is
not gonna be the last game
all right so we have a french let's play
another
um
you know as we say the
not that peter needs any more ego but
the geonato's french
um
now you guys
should already know what that entails
right the normal move is c3 here but the
way that we have played this the last
couple of frenches is this weird looking
move knight f3 knight
c6 and now does anybody remember
the proper continuation here if we are
playing in the spirit of the gambit
who can remember
who can remember the move here it's not
c3 so that's the whole point we're
avoiding c3
so
we simply develop as if nothing is
happening
so if you look at this bishop on f1
we want to develop this bishop and we go
bishop d3
now why not bishop b5 that's something i
will explain after the game it's a very
very common mistake in these positions
to go bishop b5
okay c takes d4
so
now we castle
we're just developing our pieces and f6
is one of the main lines
alright so um
a couple of things here the whole the
zen of the system here for white is to
establish full control over the e5
square if we lose control of the e5
square
then uh black's pieces start to rumble
sorry black's pawns start to rumble up
the board right
so what we do not want to do is just
take on f6 and relinquish our control
over that square we don't want to do
that so what should we do
yeah we should go rookie one or bishop
f4 one of these moves to establish
control of that pawn
the rookie one
is what we're gonna do
because okay now we take
the whole point here is that we're
maintaining our control over this square
knight f6
all right
um
how should we develop this bishop to
um
to properly maintain our control of that
square where should we go should we go
to g5 should we pin the knight
don't get distracted by the possibility
of pinning the knight
remember what our goal here is our goal
is not necessarily the one move pins our
goal is further control of the e5 square
so i believe that
even though it looks a little bit lame
bishop f4 positionally is the better
decision bishop d6
and now we need even further control of
the square because the whole battle is
revolving around our ability to preserve
this knight on e5
and i think that if you're thinking
about it how can we involve another
piece to defend that knight well we can
go queenie too that's absolutely true
but we also have a piece that we haven't
developed yet so let's try to combine
two things in one let's try to develop
this knight and bring it to a square
where it defends the e59 you guys see
what i'm getting at i think we should
play knight t2 and then possibly knight
df3
let's go knight df-3
and
what to watch for we need to watch this
x-ray our bishop is undefended so there
are potential discoveries such as 94. i
don't think they're dangerous but
we should be aware of that and one good
prophylactic move would be to drop the
bishop back to g3 when time permitting
of course
when we have the opportunity to do so
just to make sure the bishop is outside
the purview of the rook and is on a
defended square
it's exactly the same principles in the
london
yeah you you establish
maximal control over the central square
as long as we have control over that
square we have compensation for our pawn
we've got a great clamp in the center
but if we lose control of the square and
black pushes that e pawn forward there
will be hell to pay
yeah i can certainly explain which of d3
afterwards
wouldn't queen to do queen d2 hit two
birds with one stone in that respect
well queen d2 i don't really love
because it
potentially walks into a skewer
and it potentially walks into 94.
so
i don't know queen d2 maybe maybe we'll
also play queen e2 it depends on what
black does in this position
am i concerned about knight h5 no knight
h5 i can always just move my bishop back
we've got enough pieces on that's why we
brought the knight to f3
so that any single piece could depart
from its its controlling post and still
will still be okay 94 i think is the
best move
all right so 94
okay so
let's try to make sense of this position
um
i've got a couple of options here
got a couple of options here
i would say that again our top priority
here should be
maximum control over the e5 square so
one thing that we could do we can just
play bishop g3
and pretend that nothing is happening
that's interesting
but i think there is a more
direct way to play here i think there's
a more direct way to play
i think that we can just capture on c6
b takes c6 is forced because the queen
hangs
and now we just take on d6
wow queen takes d6 that's surprising
i thought that he would take with a
knight and in that case we would have
brought that other knight out to e5
okay so now we play bishop takes c4
and a very common mistake here would be
to pre-move rook takes c4 never pre-move
a move unless you are 100 sure that is
the movie should be playing always take
a couple of seconds just to make sure
that you're not missing any interesting
opportunities this is a great example of
that rook takes c4 looks great but let's
calculate one move further what happens
there rook takes c4 black plays c5
and opens up a massive diagonal for that
bishop we're not better there
what we can do
is play the move queen takes d4 this is
a typical idea we're hitting the queen
and in the event of a queen trade black
is left with you know black's pawn
structure is completely in shambles
so it was a mistake for him not to take
on d6 with the knights
why couldn't we immediately win the pawn
because if we had taken on e4 here
black would have had the additional
option of taking the other bishop the
dark squared bishop
so we had to take on d6
now we're better
that i could have removed
and let's see if we can take this all
the way to the end
c5
all right where'd you go with the knight
again the priority should be
i mean we we would like to win some of
these ponds if possible
uh but we don't want to just aimlessly
move to a square that looks good
we want to be very targeted in our in
our maneuvers so i i think knight b3 is
the best because it hits the spawn and
if the pawn goes forward the further
forward it goes the weaker it becomes we
can go night a5 or knight d2
not scary simon with a full year of
subbing thank you sir
much appreciated
okay rook b8 good move
30 bucks for miasma oh my god damn
we are getting
lit tonight rip takes c4 and this also
conveniently stops the move pawn to c4
and there come the first material losses
for black and he just resigns
yeah
um probably not even that premature the
position is just lost
um the position is just lost
so good game
all right
so
again if you've watched the speed run
before you should be familiar with this
this line that i've played the last
couple times we faced the french
um
[Music]
and the idea is to accelerate white's
development originally it was played by
aaron nimesovich
and uh the way that i would explain the
idea is
everything revolves around the e5 pawn
um
the main drawback of the french is that
that you allow this you allow the spawn
to drive itself to e5
that
in turn
locks up that bishop on c8 that's why
you get the french bishop and black is
lacking in space number one number two
black has a hard time developing his
king side pieces
to natural squares
now there's a very strong pawn like this
and that pawn is traded there's often a
weak square that emerges in its in its
steed right
so for instead so for example
you saw that in this game when black
plays f6
and then takes on e5 that's a potential
outpost so a pawn can be replaced with a
piece
but it's incredibly important not to
relinquish that square because then
black sets the pawns in motion as i
explained
um
no yeah so knight c6 bishop d3
we also
want black to play c4 because then the
bishop just drops back
and our central pawn chain is no longer
under any pressure if that makes sense
okay so c takes d4 oh yeah why not
bishop b5 so this is a very common
mistake at around a 14 1500 level is to
play bishop b5 here
where does this mistake come from i
think
a lot of players let's say below 2000
are overly not obsessed but have a
[Music]
over
over estimate let's just say the power
of a pin
and something i shared many many months
ago when i was first starting the five
minute speed run
is a short and quick way of determining
whether a pin is dangerous
so
this is the the pinning piece the bishop
uh the king sorry the knight is
the piece that is pinned
um
and the king is what i call the penny
right p-i-n-e-e just as a way to refer
to it
um
now the key question here is whether the
pin piece is protected by a pawn if a
pinned piece is protected by a pawn the
pin
is generally not as dangerous the most
dangerous pins are ones where the pinned
piece is not protected by a pawn that
way it's incredibly vulnerable and
easier to attack
um the second thing that you should be
asking yourself
um
when you're pinning something is whether
there is a way to apply further pressure
on the pin piece and that's
that's irrespective of whether there is
upon defending the pin piece so for
instance is there a way to quickly get
the queen of a4 what happens if you do
that is this pin really dangerous so
let's take a look at it is it dangerous
first of all the knight's defended by
the pawn so condition one has already
failed
but number two black could simply play
a6 or black could even play bishop d7
and the pin is no more and you certainly
do not want to give this bishop away for
the knight for no reason because then
the light squares are going to get weak
black as a gazillion moves here queen b6
the bishop is very awkward on b5 and
even if black plays a6 and you take this
pawn structure is not bad
as we've discussed many times and you've
got doubled pawns
one of the pawns could capture on d4 and
then the other one could move on to c5
this is actually a very dangerous
situation for white
if you play c3 here boom and boom and
this is an event a case where double
pawns are actually good
so i hope that makes sense um
pins on the queen side like this are
rarely that dangerous so we go bishop d3
the bishop aims at the king side because
black is very likely to castle in the
future
okay so f6 rookie one
fv5 95
five bucks from premiere bust thank you
and the lucas mitso thank you for the
three months
okay
knight f6
bishop f4 f6 is pretty good here i think
black is fine uh black was fine all the
way until
essentially he
um
played
uh took the wrong way took on d6 with
the queen so bishop d6 92 castles and an
idea of three
um look at how many pieces we have
protecting this e5 square
and the black goes 94.
okay so
i actually think 94 might be an
inaccuracy probably queen c7 was the
best move and the computer gives
equality so it's a very double-edged
position we would have dropped our
bishop back to g3
and i would argue that white's position
is easier to play even if it's
objectively equal white's got all these
really healthy and nice improving moves
queen e2 rook d1 you could try expanding
on the queen side
but black is really clamped out
so in order to play these positions well
black has to know a series of
of um
french specific maneuvers and one of
them
is to try to get this bishop around to
h5 this is a very common idea in the
french so bishop d7 queen e2 and maybe
bishop ea the problem here is that e6
bond is very weak so the moment black
relinquishes control of it plane knight
takes c6 and here we win a piece
so that's not possible sorry black might
have to go rook a8 but now this bishop
on d7 has no no good home
so
um i i hope this makes sense uh white
has full compensation for the pawn and
so it's entirely possible that from a
practical standpoint
the system where black plays bishop c5
and then bishop d7
and either delays or doesn't play f6 at
all is easier to play for black than
this one
okay so f6 or q1 blah blah blah knight
e4 and now we take take and take
and the funny thing is after knight
takes d6
the computer just says that we should
play knight takes d4 with an advantage
because this is actually a fork
and after queen f6
a very instructive position arises
um
what should y do
we have two candidate moves right black
threatens potentially to take one of
these two pieces
the key question is should we take on c6
or should we prefer some other move
so let's answer the question should we
take on c6
a lot of you say no
what if i were to tell you that the
answer is yes we should take on c6 and
i'm not trolling
you guys are looking at this saying what
the hell is wrong with you why would you
ever allow queen takes f2 and the fear
of checks
i think the reason you're probably
disgusted at this is because i think a
lot of players have a fear of the
opponent
capturing something with check this is a
very specific fear and i've noticed this
even in students or masters the fear of
opponent capturing a piece or a pawn
with check
um and it's very easy to blow that out
of proportion in your mind but look at
what happens after king h1
who does the opening of the f-file
actually benefit
well think about that for a second black
is not developed black is passive our
bishop's aimed at the king queen h5 is
threatened and we're threatening to go
rook f1 and create massive pressure down
that f-file so for instance after bishop
d7 here we would go queen h5 and black
is already losing
black has already lost g6
and
now we can go 97 check or we can go
bishop takes g6
this is the best king g7
taking the knight on
d6 um
so
this is um
this is a good example of where taking
on f2 is entirely not dangerous
well rook f1 is threatened right now
because blackstrokes are not coordinated
um
do i have any illustrative
examples of when i did something like
this i do
rook f1 queen c5 is the only movie queen
v6 yeah
let me see if i can find it
so this was a game which i butchered
even though i was winning
but um it's very very sad that i
butchered this game because it was one
of my better
one of my best uh attacking games and
then i screwed it up in the end
unfortunately but it's still
this is my game against shabala from the
2017 us championship
and we reached this very sharp position
and a classical sicilian
okay
so what's going on here well i've
castled black hasn't black's king is
clearly in quite some trouble this
knight on h5 is a really strong attacker
and here i was able to find a really
powerful move and if you if you know
anything about the classical sicilian
this move should probably occur to you
um generally this this is more common
when
when white has a pawn on before how do
we generally break apart black's pawns
bond bumper here
how do we how do we usually approach it
what typical move do we have in such
positions and again usually when we have
a bond on e4
yeah so the move f5 and i played it
anyway
and the reason is that after bishop
takes f5 this is just horrendous for
black knight g7
and black has irish puns and this is
just absolutely atrocious so it works
tactically
and if black plays e5 the point is that
the d5 square is weakened sorry no we
don't go rook d5 but we can go bishop c4
and
just positionally black is unable to
cover the square
okay but if you look even more carefully
f5 looks like a huge blunder
what why does it look like a blunder
what what move does black have here
so rook c8 yeah roxy
rook c8
and um it looks like white white is
busted because if the queen moves then
bishop takes c2 check and not only is it
a capture with a check but also the rook
is lost but i was able to calculate
further than that
queen e3
he takes and king a1
and the point is that if bishop takes d1
there's bishop b5 check
and queen h6 with checkmate so the
attack rages on this bishop is entirely
innocuous and after rook c5 i calmly
move the rook away my king is perfectly
safe if anything he did me a favor by
sending the king over to a1
the white's attack is decisive here but
in the end i i screwed it up i had a one
move win
but but in any case the reason i show
this game is just to show you that these
moves are not always to be feared
sometimes you have to calculate a little
bit deeper than just
that move where your opponent takes
something with check
okay
so back to the game
yeah after queen d6 i think the rest is
pretty simple queen takes d4
um rook v8 was another mistake probably
c4 gave more practical chances but after
knight c5 or knight a5
um white is
technically winning here
so again the system works even at a
pretty high level and uh
something that you can definitely
consider playing i'll probably make a
video on it at some point
all right well we got one more game in
the speedrun left i'm gonna leave that
one for tomorrow guys i'm pretty tired
it's late i'm gonna hit the sack and i
also want to raid min
thank you everybody
[Music]